hey folks and welcome to reality check
there was anything like this ever
happened to you hey Rob hey game of
hearthstone sure
so are we playing let's do it
damn it damn it damn it Rob hacks so Rob
insists he's just played a lot of the
game and is much better than me and that
I should stop being a whiny little well
perhaps he's right
or maybe he's using cheap BOTS so to
help me find out the truth
and then hopefully rub that truth all
over Rob stupid cheating face I
recruited malware researcher Chris Boyd
aka paper ghost to advise me so I
started by asking him to explain to me
exactly what cheap bots are and how they
work
cheap pots have been around for a long
long time in gaming anyway there's an
online environment where people are
competing or trying to win that will be
bought whenever generally two types of
bots are over the so-called chief Botts
typically prevalent in first-person
shooters there will be war hacks that
will be aimed bots there will be cheats
where people can see through the scenery
clip through the scenery so called god
mode and then on the other side of the
fence there's financial and monetary
gain so massively multiplayer games like
World of Warcraft EVE Online you get
these so called gold farmers they will
mind the high level items in the game
and they will try and sell these items
for real cash so how can we as players
go about spotting these cheap bots so
world of warcraft there are certain
signs that you're you're actually in the
presence of a bot so you can try and
talk to the bottle and send on a mode it
won't respond they will they will
perform very bizarre actions in the game
they will sort of stumble around almost
as if they're drunk and you can stand
there and watch these things for hours
at a time while you're farming yourself
legitimately they will certain types of
armor they will perform certain types of
tasks in game but but again some of
these might just be signs of someone
that just wants to get on with their own
legit farming they might not be talking
to you because they want to get on with
what they're doing maybe they're drunk
it's quite possible yet okay time to get
specific about hearthstone is Rob
cheating me or not and how can I tell
surprisingly we find a lot of the bottom
half stone aren't always playing to win
they're plain to be as fast as they can
possibly be in the matches of the aim
isn't to win the aim is to play through
as many matches as possible on the basis
that the quicker they can get through
all of these individual matches the more
matches they will eventually win so you
will find that they stack their decks to
be very fast or very aggressive okay
fine so Rob probably isn't cheating me
but for those people who do why do they
do it now with the gold farmers
mentioned earlier sure there is a
financial aspect with the selling of
rare items but according to Chris money
is not the main reason people turn to
cheat BOTS there is an aspect of you
know be
best without having to put to work and
but there are people who are just very
very opposed to any sort of grind aspect
of any title because so many games if
you're going to play it online if you're
gonna play against other people there's
only so much content that you can
possibly get through in a space of weeks
or months but there is a financial
incentive but a lot of people especially
in first-person shooters they just want
to win but what if you play on ps4 or
Xbox one or any console for that matter
can these bot makers get their code
running on these machines - it's very
difficult because the console is a
closed sort of environment it's very
hard to get Road code running gone on a
so called leisure console it's a it's a
lot easier to compromise and temper a PC
with all these things whether it's BOTS
whether it's malware whether it's
fishing or social engineering it's
always the path of least resistance so
if it's if it's a lot more easier to go
off and target someone on these these
more open platforms and this sort of
closed-loop technology the that exists
on these games consoles you're gonna go
with PC so how much of a problem are
these cheap bots for the industry and
how are the publishers combating them
and bringing the fight to the people who
make them well that's exactly what part
two of this cheap bot special is going
to be all about and your bill to watch
that the week after next until then I'd
love to hear about your thoughts and
experiences with cheap BOTS you can
leave me a comment in the box below or
of course as always Twitter and I'm at
cam 4 as Rob next episode is going to be
all about the science of the order 1886
so expect where wills electricity guns
and Nikola Tesla I'll see you then
you